.
Liebe Bundesregierung,
liebes Klimakabinett, am Freitag
habt ihr das hier herausgebracht,
und viele fragen sich nur eins:
nämlich WTF?
Nein, Herr Söder, so werden wir
unsere Klimaziele nicht erfüllen
und die Welt für unsere Kinder
nicht erhalten.
Ich will kurz erklären, warum nicht.
über vieles haben wir ja schon
gesprochen, zur Erreichung unserer
Klimaziele brauchen wir ein
CO2-Preis, lasst uns über die Höhe
dieses Preises sprechen, denn hier
liegt der wichtigste Knackpunkt.
Aus dieser Expertise vom
Mercator Institut für Klimaforschung
und und dem Potsdam Institut für
Klimafolgenforschung wird deutlich:
wenn wir unsere Klimaziele erreichen
wollen, dann ist ein CO2 Preis
alleine zwar noch nicht die Lösung,
aber ein CO2 Preis muss
die Hauptrolle spielen
in dem Maßnahmenpaket.
Er muss die Hauptmaßnahme sein,
der alle anderen notwendigen
Zusatzmaßnahmen untergeordnet sind.
Hier besteht ein
wissenschaftlicher Konsens.
Eine Hauptrolle kann ein CO2 Preis
nur spielen, wenn der Preis stimmt.
Der Preis darf nicht zu niedrig sein,
wenn man im Geldbeutel nichts spürt,
dann gibt es auch
keine Verhaltensänderung,
weder vom einzelnen und auch
nicht von der Industrie oder Banken.
Wenn man aber etwas spürt, dann führt
ein CO2 Preis zu einem Sammeleffekt,
weil wir jetzt einen universellen
Anreiz für alle haben,
der die Vermeidung von CO2-Ausstoß
attraktiv macht.
Dieser Universalanreiz ist das, was
wir unter Lenkungswirkung verstehen.
Und wie in dieser Lenkungswirkung
wird der CO2 Preis als
Hauptinstrument empfohlen.
Das Ganze ist sozial gerecht möglich,
mit Entlastung von Niedrigverdienern.
Dazu kommen wir gleich.
Wie hoch sollte der CO2 Preis also
sein, damit er diese wichtige
Rolle übernehmen kann.
Das haben die Experten berechnet:
Zumindest, wenn wir unsere
Klimaziele erreichen wollen,
was die Regierung ja will, sagt sie.
Statt Steuer oder Festpreis kann
man auch auf das Konzept
Emissionshandel setzen:
da gibt es ein festes CO2-Budget.
Also eine maximal Menge an CO2,
die ausgestoßen werden darf.
Die Höhe des CO2-Preises wird beim
Emissionshandel durch die Höhe
des CO2-Budgets bestimmt, also
durch die CO2-Menge, die maximal
ausgestoßen werden darf, denn die
genauen Preise ergeben sich dann
durch Angebot und Nachfrage.
Und je weniger Ausstoßungsrechte
vorhanden sind, desto höher wird
der Preis.
Jetzt gibt es aber folgendes Problem:
es gibt neue technische,
klimafreundliche Innovationen,
die dafür sorgen,
dass weniger CO2 ausgestoßen wird.
Super, dass wollen wir, aber dadurch
sinkt der CO2-Preis, d.h.,
CO2-Ausstoß wird an anderer Stelle
wieder attraktiver, und das führt
dann wieder zu mehr Emissionen.
Deshalb empfehlen Experten einen
Mindestpreis für die Tonne CO2,
der nicht unterschritten werden darf.
Auch ein Höchstpreis pro Tonne CO2,
der nicht überschritten werden darf,
kann sinnvoll sein, auch wenn es
zunächst kontraproduktiv klingt.
Aber eine Klima- und Energiewende
muss längerfristig planbar sein.
Ich muss heute schon investieren,
um in 20 Jahren gut dazustehen.
Ein Prieskorridor, also ein
Mindest- und Höchstpreis,
sorgt für Planungssicherheit und
erleichtert damit klimafreundliche
Investitionen.
Wenn der Mindest-und Höchstpreis
ausreichend hoch sind, geht auch
die Lenkungswirkung nicht verloren.
So ein Emissionshandel mit
Preiskorridor ist also eine Art
Verschmelzung aus dem freien
Emissionshandel mit der CO2-Steuer,
den Fixpreisen,
was durchaus seine Vorteile hat.
Für den Preiskorridor
gibt es folgende Berechnungen:
im Jahr 2020 mindestens 35 Euro
pro Tonne CO2, maximal 70 Euro,
bis 2030 dann ein Anstieg
auf 70-180 Euro.
Das sind die Preise, die mit
unseren Klimazielen kompatibel sind.
Liegen die Preise darunter,
verfehlt das Instrument CO2-Preis
seine Wirkung.
Dann schauen wir doch mal, was sich
das Klimakabinett der Bundesregierung
dazu überlegt hat:
der Plan ist es, in den Sektoren
Verkehr und Gebäude mit
einem CO2-Fixpreis anzufangen,
der mit der Zeit ansteigt und dann
übergeht in einen Emissionshandel
mit Preiskorridor.
Das mit dem Ziel, dass
auch auf EU-Ebene zu installieren.
Dieser Plan ist gut.
Nur die Preise sind leider ungeil.
Effekt: ein CO2-Preis von 10 Euro
sorgt an der Tankstelle für nur
3 Cent mehr pro Liter Benzin.
Das liegt weit
unter den täglichen Schwankungen.
In der Süddeutschen wurde
sehr verständlich aufgearbeitet,
wie weit dieser Plan von der
wissenschaftlichen Empfehlung
entfernt ist.
Wir werden am Ende dieses
Klimapakets, im Jahr 2026,
mit dem CO2 Preis in
keinem wirksamen Bereich liegen.
Ihr seht, dass der dann
angedachte Maximalpreis eher auf
Minimalpreisniveau liegt.
Jetzt kann man sagen, was ist
mit den ganzen anderen Maßnahmen?
All die Prämien, Förderungen und
Investitionen, da kann man sich jetzt
tot diskutieren, in all den Details,
sei es die Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer bei Bahntickets
überhaupt zu einer
Verhaltensänderung führen wird
oder ob die Abwrackprämie bei
Ölheizungen nicht viel zu
langsam ist.
Aber eigentlich ist all das nur eine
Ablenkung von dem eigentlichen
Grundproblem: nämlich
das Fehlen eines übergeordneten,
lenkenden CO2-Preises.
Was hier vorgestellt wird, ist ein
Flickenteppich aus Ordnungsrecht und
Förderung ohne wirksamen CO2-Preis,
wovon die Experten abgeraten haben.
Weil so ein Flickenteppich lässt sich
nicht einfach auf EU-Ebene übertragen
Weil er nicht effizient ist und auch
schwer sozial gerecht umsetzbar ist.
Noch mal, die Experten sagen nicht,
dass solche ordnungsrechtlichen
Maßnahmen Quatsch sind, und dass
ein CO2-Preis alles ist, sondern sie
sagen, solche Maßnahmen müssen einen
CO2-Preis begleiten, wir brauchen
erst den Preis, und dann können wir
schauen, wo sind die Stellen, an
denen der Preis alleine nicht reicht
und dort setzen wir Prämien,
Förderungen und Verbote.
Nehmen wir die Pendlerpauschale als
Beispiel, die für Fern-Pendler
erhöht werden soll und zwar in einem
ziemlichen Missverhältnis zu den
minimal steigenden Spritpreisen.
Effekt: wenn ich mit dem Auto 50 km
zur Arbeit pendle, dann kostet mich
das mit dem Klimapaket
im Jahr 2021 weniger als heute.
Aber wenn man davon absieht,
dann schießt das Grundprinzip
dieser Pendlerpauschale
am Ziel vorbei.
Wenn ich Pendler bin, dann habe ich
ja nur einen Anreiz, mein Auto stehen
zu lassen und auf klimafreundliche
Alternativen zu wechseln, wenn der
CO2 Preis hoch genug ist, also
wenn Autofahren spürbar teurer wird
als klimafreundliche Alternativen.
Wenn ich natürlich keine Alternativen
habe, z.B. im ländlichen Raum,
dann muss der Ausbau
solcher Alternativen, z.B.
Öffentlicher Verkehr
an erster Stelle stehen.
Das ist jetzt ein schönes Beispiel
dafür, wo der CO2-Preis alleine
nicht reicht und wo man hier gezielt
zusätzliche Maßnahmen einführen kann.
Eine Pendlerpauschale ist ohne
wirksamen CO2-Preis, zwar eine
finanzielle Entlastung der Pendler,
hat aber keine Lenkungswirkung, es
wird also kein Verhalten ändern.
Eine sinnvollere und gerechtere
Lösung wäre es, wenn man einen
CO2-Preis hat, der entsprechend hoch
ist, und die Einnahmen aus dem
Klimadividende oder
indem man die Stromsteuern senkt.
Das hatten wir
auch schon im letzten Video.
Eine Senkung der Stromkosten wird im
Klimapaket zwar vorgestellt, aber
es fehlt wieder die sinnvolle
Kopplung mit einem ausreichend
hohen CO2-Preis.
Diese Grafik des Mercator Instituts
bringt die Vorteile auf den Punkt:
ein wirksam hoher CO2-Preis plus
Klimadividende und plus Senkung
der Stromsteuer stärkt die Schwachen
und wirkt auf dem Land und in der
Stadt fast gleich.
Also anstatt einen Wust von
Förderungen und Prämien blind zu
setzen, empfehlen die Experten
das System CO2-Preis plus
Klimadividende als
Hauptinstrument einzusetzen
und davon ausgehen, dann auch zu
schauen, wer bleibt jetzt noch
als Härtefall zurück.
Je höher der CO2 Preis, desto mehr
Geld haben wir für einen sozialen
Ausgleich.
Nicht zuletzt ist der CO2-Preis eine
wichtige Einnahmequelle und eine
Antwort auf die Frage,
wer soll das alles bezahlen.
Da nun die CO2-Preise aber viel zu
niedrig sind, ist dieses Klimapaket
nichts anderes als eine Aufschiebung
des Problems um ein paar Jahre.
Und dafür haben wir keine Zeit
mehr, es ist nicht mehr 5 vor 12,
es ist schon 5 nach 12.
Unsere Ziele für 2020
sind ja quasi schon verfehlt.
Die Bundesregierung hat sich aber
dazu verpflichtet, sich von einem
externen Expertenrat begleiten zu
lassen, der auf die Einhaltung
der Klimaziele schaut.
Und sie hat sich verpflichtet,
den Kurs anzupassen, wenn wir
unsere Ziele verfehlen.
Liebe Bundesregierung, liebes
Klimakabinett es ist jetzt schon
klar, dass wir uns auf einem Kurs
befinden, auf dem wir unsere
Klimaziele krachend verfehlen werden.
Aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht habt ihr
also das Go, ihr könnt euch jetzt
schon wieder zusammensetzen.
Wenn euch unsere Klimaziele ernsthaft
wichtig sind, dann müsst ihr euch
jetzt wieder zusammensetzen.
Und vielleicht das nächste Mal
nicht in einer Nachtsitzung.
Nicht in der Nacht, wenn es darum
geht, gewinnt denn Gesäß oder Gehirn.
Das ist doch aberwitzig, eine
solche komplexe und komplizierte
Angelegenheiten in einer
Nachtsitzung zu besprechen.
Sondern vielleicht
mal in einem Rahmen, der einer
Menschheitsaufgabe gerecht wird.
Dank Fridays for Future habt ihr der
Wissenschaft endlich Gehör geschenkt
und euch an eure Klimaziele erinnert.
Für die Erreichung der Klimaziele
steht euch die wissenschaftliche
Expertise weiterhin zur Verfügung.
Und wenn ihr nur den Mut habt,
die auch anzuwenden, dann dürft ihr
nächstes Mal auch ernsthaft
verkünden, dass endlich einiges
auf den Weg gebracht wurde,
um den Klimawandel aufzuhalten.
Und all diese Leute
würden euch endlich mal feiern.
Wäre das nicht fantastisch?
Untertitel: ARD Text
Im Auftrag von funk (2019)